welcome back everyone
today we'll be animating a planet
transition right in figma
we've got a source file ready for you so
you can inspect the file and follow
along step by step just check the link
below this video download the file and
we're good to go alright let's Dive
Right In
as you can see we already have a
collection of Planet images ready these
images are sourced from the journey an
AI art generator app that helps you
create beautiful Unique Images in just a
few seconds if you're not familiar with
my journey or how to use it I recommend
to watch our mid-journey tutorial you'll
find the link for it in the description
below the video we also have a basic
layout for a website hero section we
have the name of a planet at the top
some information about it just below the
name and to add a bit of magic to the
design there are glows and a star system
in the background we'll be working with
all these elements throughout this
tutorial
the first step is to bring one of the
planets into the center of the hero
section
next we'll select two other planets
resize them to be smaller than the
central planet and place one on each
side of the frame they will be used to
switch between planets in the animation
adjust the positioning of the two
planets so that approximately only half
of each one is visible on the screen now
we're going to add names for both of
these planets right next to them
[Music]
with this done we're ready to duplicate
the entire frame
in the new frame we're going to replace
the planet in the center
to do this we'll add a new fill to the
layer click on the plus sign next to
fill and select an image of another
planet
we can now remove the original fill by
clicking on the minus sign next to it
make sure to change the opacity of the
new fill to 100 to fully display the new
planet now we can update the colors of
the shadows and blurs to match our new
planet
this creates a cool atmospheric effect
now we need to rotate the planet by 60
degrees
[Music]
let's not forget about our star system
in the background rotate it by 60
degrees but this time in the opposite
direction lastly to keep everything in
harmony we'll update the colors of the
blurs and also the planet's name and
information to match the new planet
moving on let's pay some attention to
the planets on the sides
the planet on the left side should be
updated with the image of the planet
that precedes the current planet in our
sequence similarly the planet on the
right side should be updated with the
image of the planet that follows
[Music]
once that's done it's time to duplicate
the frame now select the central planet
and give it another 60 degree rotation
replacing the planet is just as simple
as before
add a new fill and select the next
planet image
then remove the previous fill
with the new planet in place it's
important to keep the aesthetic
consistent
so let's update the shadows and blurs to
match the new planet's hues
don't forget to also update the planet's
information as for the small planets on
the sides they need to be updated as
well keeping in line with our sequence
of planets
[Music]
and of course we can't forget our star
system in the background
rotate it in the opposite direction by
60 degrees
now let's duplicate the frame one last
time and repeat the process for our
final planet
[Music]
once that's complete we're ready to dive
into the prototyping phase switch to the
Prototype tab on the top right of your
screen in our first frame select the
small planet on the right
and drag a connection line from it to
the second frame
for the interaction details select smart
animate with quick easing and set the
duration to 900 milliseconds
next select the planet on the left from
the second frame connect it with the
previous frame ensure to set the same
interaction details as before follow
these steps for all the frames
[Music]
thank you
once everything is connected it's time
to preview the Prototype and see our
animation in action if you've enjoyed
this tutorial and you're interested in
leveling up your ux UI design skills do
check out our ux UI design Mastery
course the link is in the description
below the video
foreign